Tactical hide-and-seek private first class sizzle wizzle. I think he's gonna do a great job
*Robotic Noise* come out with your hands up
Heat signature detected
You might have heard of hide-and-go-seek but this isn't your three-year-old niece's birthday party that's right today
We're playing extreme tactical hide-and-seek you guys ready?
im ready
It's real simple. The terrorists are hiding
the counter terrorists are seeking terrorists job is to either kill the counter terrorists or bonk him on the head with a
Manifesto scroll then that CT converts to becoming a terrorist for the next round and it's up to his comrades to save him
This is gonna be really hard because once you hide you can't move you can only attack if the CT is within attacking range
It's gonna get dangerous in here
Strategy's simple walk slow carry a big gun. I hope I don't get bonked by a manifesto
it changes my mind, makes me to become a radical. That won't happen!
I haven't thought at all about where to hide
I'm trying to get a spot where I can attack very quickly one two - okay
So let's do ill know they're here and I can get him four five
i'm gonna create a decoy
six
Seven eight woah nice
Nine
Ten all right hey Ct buddies you guys ready Hey, yeah, you guys will be great. Listen
Im gonna go in
You guys have your stuff on I'll probably handle it. But get your stuff on? I'll be ready when you're here
Okay, here we go whenever there's trouble we send in the best
You could be anywhere especially under the stairs
My back is totally exposed right there didn't get attacked what if they're under the stairs man look they're not under there
No terrorist in there
*Gun Shot* Ah *Gun shot* *Gun shot*
I knew it, I knew it. Three shots
*Gun shot*
No, they didn't work as well as I was hoping it would I'm thinking that both Jarrett and Jake picked the most obvious hiding spots
they could *Gun shot*
I Knew it. Counter terrorist. He's dead I got him.
If he had come a couple more feet. I could've bonked him
I stepped in an said this place looks inconspicuous
Mm-hmm. I'll shoot through the crack in the door just to be safe
and then christian dies.
I would have probably ducked under the cushion
Alright,  here go tell my friends we got good news
He was about to walk in the room to
Wait you got everyone, yeah I got everyone
Send in the best. Yeah, I wasn't even worried. That was just as I expected this no
It's too easy right now for the CT
We need to make it harder if Jarrett didn't constrain himself in a barrel and you were crouched down like this
It has some maneuverability you guys have been okay, Christian would have almost gotten me
Next round would be better once the terrorists learn from their mistakes
Do the exact same thing again tactical Billy?
tactical billy
Terrorists are going down. I'm gonna make him smile.
Feel like everyone just had a practice round against Niko and I have to go in there now against a more experienced terrorists
How am I expected to win here?
It might be someone behind the door the moment you open it under this
and
Without even entering I'll open it and I'll look through the crack
You should breach by kicking the door open as hard as possible and letting it swing and crush whoever's standing behind it
Swish you in? Yeah
That's not bad. That's really good action. Yeah, we're ready
Hey Terrorists want some freedom. No too bad
*Gun shot* laughing you got me. ah it worked
Oh no
Do you think anyone went upstairs its bright up there? Why would anyone hide up there?
Oh, gosh, I can't really see through these goggles in this darkness
This is quite freaky. Oh, I don't want to have to go into the tunnel of chains
Okay, can I just like turn on the lights. Nope. I don't want to go in there
I don't Like this, hey I got some reconstituted Constitution. Hey Jarrett come out
Did really no-one hide back here
What are you doing are you hiding? Yeah, dude, you're giving away my spot today's episode guys sponsored by raid Shadow Legends
It's this game right here
I just downloaded it a couple days ago and I've been playing it since we have a lot of downtime during this hide-and-seek game
I wanted to tell you a little bit about this game. It's one of the most ambitious RPG mobile games out there. That's right
It's got everything you might expect from a brand-new RPG game. I just downloaded a few days ago. It's got amazing story
It's got 3d graphics. It's got a bunch of different types of champions you can play as. The game's good
It's getting big fast. Try to get in early
They're doing a special launch tournament upcoming here real soon and it's gonna be giving out
real-life physical prize packs
all you have to do to download raid is click the link in the description of this video right here and you'll get
50,000 silver plus a free epic champion right away as a courtesy. Anyway, I just wanted to let you guys know
Oh shhh
I feel like I checked everywhere
Except for back here
where did everyone go
*Gunshot*
*Jake moaning*
Freedom you are freed from life. I am running long time
The President!
Oh god Oh god
That was you?
-Yeah
Ahhhh!
Terrorists got this round
You were right here. yeah I was behind the barrel
I... I... I saw. I thought I saw this
I think you even touched it a one point
I did. I even kinda manu- And I just held my breath and went
We didn't want to have to do this but one of the C T's went down and it's time to bring in one of the
Big guns a super soldier the best of the best. Is he a man?
Is he a God or is he hell on two feet? Well, if you're a terrorist, he's all three
I'm the ultra special operator private first class sizzle Wizzle. I think he's gonna do a great job feeling very good about his
loss of words for myself at a loss of words for the energy that the vibes I was getting it is up to you and
Your nocturnal camera the hottest of bodies need you get in there. I'm just you do work you understand
Yeah, My code name is sizzle wizzle because I can pick up down heat lines
There's a little see those, you know, those little wavy heat lines that come on. Yeah
That's like a magnet for me. I spent 99% of my life in the dark. So I'm an expert on dark areas
Reclaim the honor that our fallen heroes have dropped on the battlefield
I'm going to totally forget it and figure out exactly where they are. No prisoners
Someone caught me there's a bunch of terrorists in here. sizzle wizzle online
That's the sound of my about camera scanning
sorry there is no way to describe these noises
Yeah, this is freaky bro, someone's got a hot speaker computer monitors are pretty hot too
Hi, this is where shit gets real boys
*Sam is making beeping scanning noises*
Come out with your hands up
Heat signature detected, heat signature fading mission success.
Oh boy
*More scanning sounds*
Heat Signature detected, someone's behind the couch come out with your hands up
Come out with your hands up criminal I can smell your heat lines
Your sizzle lines that comes straight off that body yeah drop that manifesto and I'll and I'll give you I'll bring you out live
Never!
The privatized health care system, we'll take care of him. Just fine two more
*Scanning noises*
Area secure
Ahhhh!
One of us one of us one of us I convinced you as my online essays
Ahh!
He got turned into a terrorist. What?
Private Sizzle Wizzle? That was good boy right there going in there as the colonel
Over his direct command. Yeah, you're next in line
Yeah, it seems that way we know that you were injured, but you asked me to come out of retirement
We're asking you to come out of retirement. God dang it
How do you were you able to do you I wouldn't do it for you. I wouldn't do it but for my country
That's a different story. Give me a gun. The only way to save him is to bonk him back with this and then he becomes
Sam again, that's only gonna work on Sam. Yes. Everyone else gets this or the knife
Can you put this can you put it in my head? Yeah, thanks. And then your knife you get a knife
Well, that's sus well this part is clear, but that's the easy part
That's a nice a nice round one appreciate it
Got ahold fly-in the flytrap
Monkey noises from above
Go down go down
That's one more terrorist, oh the red light is off
You got no lights now, I feel like I'm gonna do them again, I think someone's in there it might be Sam
Angry howler monkey noises
Come join me! Haha. Come and join me! Come and join me!
Come and join- Ahh!
Sam? What the shell is I doing in here?
It's good to see you boy. Good to see you
You hold this oh, it's good with you colonel feel it baby back in my hands
Jarrett please just to put him out of his misery. Okay? Okay. It must be miserable wherever he is and he's back here
Check this room. No heat signatures detected
*Screaming and bike horn honking*
Oh wait! It's a conversion tool!
Freakin geniuses another day saved
Well, I think everyone's seen what happens when you use a thermal camera to play hide and seek it gets pretty extreme
and I think it's a bloodbath all around but I'm just glad that Sam and Clint both got out alive now if you're interested in
Seeing some other games like this leave a comment below or turn that notification
Bell on because we do stuff like this more often than you might think as a bunch of grown men